The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: OK,
so last time, we
were talking about the
[? massive ?] Sudakov form
factor.
We're going to continue
that discussion today.
And we saw that in order
to do this calculation,
we needed to have
additional regulator
besides dimensional
regularization.
This was an example in SCT2
where we had these rapidity
divergences.
And so there is this
additional regulator
that led to these 1 over
8 eta poles in our answer
and these logs of nu as well.
And we said that if you
stare at these results
that you could see where you
would need to take those scale
parameters in order to
minimize these logarithms.
And it is such that in
the collinear diagrams,
you need to take nu
of order p minus.
And p minus is the hard scale.
And you want you mu
of order m, which
is this scale of the hyperbola.
And in the soft,
you want nu and mu
to be the same size and
then both of order m.
So what we'll do in
a minute is we'll--
so you can imagine
what happens next.
You add some counter terms,
remove these 1 over epsilon
poles and 1 over eta poles.
You're left with something
that's a finite result that's
a function of the cutoffs.
And you put things together.
When you put things
together, the cutoffs
should cancel out of
the physical observable,
which here was the form factor.
So the form of the
factorization theorem for this--
so you have some hard function.
It's just the
Wilson coefficient,
some collinear function
which I'll can cn,
cn bar, and then
some soft function.
And so it's the usual
story in some sense,
but we have this additional
dependence on a parameter nu,
not just mu.
OK, so this same statements
I was making up there kind
of encoded in the arguments.
You want mu to be of order m.
You want nu to be of order
q, mu to be of order m nu
to be of order q, mu to
be of order m, nu to be of
[? order mu, ?]
which is order m.
So I could have written
nu over m here as well.
OK, and then there's also
some hard factor that
really looks at the hard scale.
So renormalization, and they
have two cut off parameters.
So what we'll
have, therefore, is
we'll have a
renormalization group
for these objects in a two
dimensional space-- mu and nu
space.
And we'll need both of those
to sum the large logarithms.
So just having
renormalization group in mu
would not be enough to
solve the large logarithms
in this problem.
So let's-- even before we--
so we'll go through it,
and we'll write down anomalous
dimensions in a minute.
But even before
we do that, let's
just picture what we
want from the running.
So here's a two
dimensional space where
we want to do that running.
So let's put mu on this
axis and nu on this axis.
Break out the color.
So we have some hard
degrees of freedom
that we're integrating
out, right?
But they live somewhere
in this picture.
So let's say here, we
have mu of order 2.
The hard degrees of freedom,
as I wrote over here,
they don't depend on nu.
We talked about that last time,
and one way of seeing it is nu
is just a parameter
that distinguishes modes
within the effective theory.
It's a regulator that was
needed to distinguish soft
from collinear, but if you
add it up these contributions,
the nu dependence and the
1 over etas all cancel.
So the hard degrees of freedom
only depend on mu and q.
And so they don't care about nu.
So we can draw them as a line.
It's hard.
They don't live
localized in that space.
But the other modes, we
could put a dot associated
with each one of them.
So you have nu of order m here.
[INAUDIBLE] equal m.
Mu equals q.
So then we need to have a low
energy mu scale, mu equals m.
So the soft modes
are going to live
at mu equals m, mu equals m.
And then the collinear mode's
going to live over here.
And the way we've set up
our calculation, we didn't--
we sort of had one cut off
for both the cn and cn bar.
So they both live
at the same point.
It could have been
more fancy, but that
suffices for doing
the calculations here.
So they both live
at nu equals q.
We basically had a--
we didn't care about whether
it was p minus or p plus.
We regulated them both with nu.
OK, so to do the
renormalization group,
this is where the
modes want to live.
But we need to connect them
because in this formula,
they all have the
same mu and nu.
So the general thing
that you could imagine
is that there's some point mu
and nu in this space, right,
and that you write down
this formula there.
But then everybody has large
logs because you're not
at the right point.
And so you have to do a
renormalization group evolution
to that point.
So the most general thing
that you could think of
would be that there would
be a renormalization
group of the hard function
down to that point.
And that's just the
whole line moves down.
So this would be
some evolution kernel
uh that would run from some
initial condition, which
I'll call uh.
I'll call this mu
equals mu h, and we'll
call this guy mu light.
Call this guy nu light.
Call this guy nu heavy.
Just have some names for them.
And then these guys here would
have running in two dimensions,
and you have to take a path
from this point to that point.
And so here's a simple path.
Just go over and then up.
Just go over, up.
And there'd be an
evolution kernel associated
with each one of these things.
So this mu 1 would
be some kernel mu
n that would run for
mu light to some mu.
And then it's at fixed new.
And this guy here will
be some other evolution
kernel which I'll call v because
it's running in nu space--
so some linear evolution
kernel that's running in
nu from some nu
heavy down to nu.
And it's at fixed nu light.
And then there would likewise
be kernels on this side.
There would be a
mu s and a vs. OK,
so that would be the
sort of general thing
that you could possibly imagine.
Now the choice at this
point is arbitrary,
and you know that
effectively that there's
consistency in the sense
that you can move that point
around and nothing changes.
So you can use your
freedom to pick this point
to make your life as
simple as possible.
If you pick it up here
at the hard scale,
you don't have to
do any uh running.
If you pick it over here
at the collinear scale,
then you don't have to
do the collinear running.
So we can do that
to simplify things.
And that's again
just the freedom--
the usual, simple freedom-- of
either running the coefficients
or running the operators.
And it's just a little
more complicated.
That's what this freedom to
move this point around is.
So this is like running
coefficients versus operators.
It's just a little
more complicated
because we have
these two cutoffs.
So let's just pick,
for example, mu and nu
to be mu light and nu heavy.
So that's putting it over
here at the orange point.
Then you would just
have evolution kernels.
The softs would just have to
run all the way over there.
So you wouldn't
need mu us either.
You would just need nu s, vs.
So you have vs, and vs would
run from starting at nu light
over to nu heavy.
So this is the
initial condition,
and this is the final.
And it's at fixed mu s.
And then you'd have
a running from uh
down to mu light from mu heavy.
OK, so then you just have
these two evolution kernels.
So it would be pretty simple.
So there's a consistency of both
moving around in the nu space.
When I move this point around,
there's a cancellation between
vn and vs, and there's also a
cancellation between the three
u's.
So there's also in this thing,
there's a path independence.
So I drew a particular path
where I went like that.
I could have drawn another path.
I could have gone up
first and then over.
And because the
parameters nu and mu
are independent parameters,
the choice of the path
doesn't matter.
We'll see that from
our calculations
as well in a minute when I write
down the anomalous dimensions.
But this is just
following from the fact
that they're
independent parameters.
And effectively,
what that means is
if you think about
taking derivatives,
you can switch the order of the
integration of the derivatives.
So mu d by d mu and nu d by d
nu is the same as nu d by d nu,
mu d by d mu.
OK.
There are examples of
effective field theories
where you would set
up cutoff parameters,
and this wouldn't be true.
You'd think maybe you
have two cut offs,
but actually, you only have one.
There's an example of
this in our QCD, where
if you try to draw
things in two dimensions,
you find out that
there's really only one
path that the effective
theory picks out.
But in this case, there really
are two cutoff parameters.
OK, so let's do that in
detail by going back over here
to these formulas, writing
down the counter terms,
deriving from those counter
terms the anomalous dimensions,
and then we can see how you
would derive these evolution
kernels in this picture.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you comment
on why sort of this
works even though the mu and
the nu and the collinear cycle
aren't, like, factorizing?
Like, for example, why couldn't
I, just right off the bat--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --regulators and never
have a factorization theorem
but run in different scales?
Like, this seems like too easy.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
it seems too easy.
It's really because
if you like the--
there's a certain-- if you think
about renormalization theorems,
which we know much
better from mu than--
there's not really
that much known for nu.
There is kind of a
renormalization theorem here
that is related to the fact
that this divergence is
really related to that iconal
propagator that we had.
And even when you go
to higher loop orders,
there's a certain universality
to that propagator that's
making this whole thing work.
So yeah.
I think this is a
relatively new thing,
and I think it hasn't
really fully been explored.
So there's probably some
interesting work to do there.
All right, so let's do it.
Let's see what counter terms
we get and how things work out.
So we're going to do
the standard thing.
Think about renormalization
the objects.
So we'll have bare objects
and renormalized objects.
Each one of these
guys corresponded
to a single collinear field.
So there's some wave function
renormalization factor,
and then there's
some renormalization
for the operator.
And together, those
two things will take us
from the bare to
the renormalization
and likewise for
[INAUDIBLE] soft guy.
In this case, there's no--
we just have Wilson lines.
So there's just a
renormalization of the object.
And this guy here, it's
the usual wave function
renormalization.
It's just the same in SET
for a collinear particle
as it is in QCD.
So just for the
record, there's a 1
over epsilon coming from
that that will modify our--
this 1 over 2 epsilon here.
Let me put it together
for the z factors.
[? So what ?] [? of ?]
[? the z's? ?] Taking those
graphs and these formulas,
find the following.
Think I dropped something.
[INAUDIBLE]
There was this pesky
factor of w squared
that we talked about last time.
But we'll need it
for this calculation.
So we simply just
subtract all the poles.
Minimal subtraction.
So I'm always going
to only just write zn
because zn bar is
really the same.
We set up our kinematics
symmetrically.
So it's really no difference
between zn and zn bar.
So there's a minus
sign plus sign there.
Comes to 3/8 epsilon.
So those are the counter
terms that we get.
AUDIENCE: Did you [INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Yes, I did.
Thank you.
And we get the anomalous
dimensions again
just by demanding the usual
thing-- that the bare objects
don't depend on mu and nu.
And we can do that
separately in the mu and nu.
So if you like, actually,
kind of along the lines
of your question,
[INAUDIBLE],, there's
a assumption built into this,
the way we wrote this, right?
I've kept the full
epsilon dependence
in my 1 over eta pole.
And that's related to
saying that I could really
think of doing all the
eta renormalization first
and then think about
doing epsilon second.
So the kind of--
we have built something into
this that's non-trivial.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
order is the same [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: You mean
that the order being--
AUDIENCE: Like that you
can do one [INAUDIBLE]
before the other.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, oh, that
the order doesn't matter.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That seems like--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --something that you
would get from a factorized
expression--
IAIN STEWART: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, it
kind of is factorized.
But it's hidden,
right, because we
are saying that this is kind
of a multiplicative thing
on that whole thing.
And that's the kind
of factorization,
although it looks kind of
like a non-factorized thing.
So let's talk about mu
anomalous dimensions.
And you'll see that in
order for this to be true,
you also don't-- it's not
the case that mu anomalous
dimension needs to be
independent of nu, for example.
So this kind of looks
like it's not factoring,
but magically, it is in
the sense of this path
independence.
So what is gamma mu
for the soft function?
So we just say that mu d by
d mu on bare things is 0 is--
so is nu d by d nu.
So that's the way
that this works.
And that gives us this
kind of standard formulas
that we're used to for
the anomalous dimensions.
So zs inverse mu d by d mu
with the appropriate sign
is the anomalous
dimension in mu.
That comes from this
equation for soft function.
So if we look at that
and we work it out,
so if you look at this term,
it actually doesn't contribute,
because in this term, alpha s
of mu times mu to the 2 epsilon
is mu independent.
So that term has no contribution
to the new anomalous dimension.
And then this term
does contribute,
and there's a contribution
from this term.
Where you differentiate
the alpha, you get a 1
over 2 epsilon.
You differentiate this
guy, and there's a--
if you differentiate
the explicit log mu,
there's also a 1 over epsilon.
Those 1 over
epsilons cancel, OK?
So there's no contribution
from this guy.
There's no contribution
from differentiating
the alpha in this guy or the
explicit log in this guy.
So the only contribution
is taking the alpha,
differentiating it,
getting a 2 epsilon,
and multiplying
that 1 over epsilon.
So this line switches,
and there's a 2.
AUDIENCE: Set w to 1?
IAIN STEWART: And
I set w to 1, yeah.
w-- renormalize w.
[INAUDIBLE] 1.
So likewise, for the other
case, for the collinear--
and this is actually the same
as [INAUDIBLE] mu and bar.
And what this gives if you
solve the anomalous dimension
equation--
so the anomalous
dimension equations
are like [INAUDIBLE]
sign convention
like this or et cetera.
So you would solve
those equations.
And those equations would give
you the kernels us and un.
And it's a simple
multiplicative rge.
So if you just-- this
is mu d by dmu of log
s, and you just integrate
the way we've done before.
And consistency
says that you could
run in this picture either way.
And that is a relation between
the anomalous dimensions.
There's also an
anomalous dimension
for the hard function.
And if we add them
all up, we get zero.
We pick the sign
conventions accordingly.
So you could write
the relation that way.
And so you can
calculate the gamma h
by knowing these three--
gamma for the hard function.
Or you could calculate
it by the counter term
for the hard function.
And as expected, it only
depends on a log of mu over q.
There's no nus in that.
So that's the mu
anomalous dimension.
It works as usual.
And the interesting thing
is that there's also
a new anomalous dimension
because the bear functions are
independent of nu.
It's the same type of formula.
We just have nu d by d nu
instead of mu d by d mu.
There's no nu dependence
in the coupling alpha,
but there is a nu
dependence in this w.
When you differentiate
the w, you get an eta
And that's where basically the
contribution is coming from.
So what happens is you
differentiate the w.
That kills this eta.
But then it looks like
your result would have a 1
over epsilon pole.
But you also have to
differentiate explicitly
this nu here.
Again, that has a 1
over epsilon pole.
So those two cancel.
Once you take the
epsilon goes to 0 limit,
they cancel, and
you're just left
with a finite
anomalous dimension.
So here, I'm always
sending epsilon to 0,
and eta goes to 0.
And that's what sets w
to 1 and stuff like that.
OK, so this guy--
so [INAUDIBLE]
cancellations [INAUDIBLE]
1 over epsilon poles
to get those results,
and there's also cancellations
of 1 over epsilon poles
to get these results.
And equations like nu d by d
nu of s [INAUDIBLE] gamma nu ss
would give the
kernel vs, et cetera.
OK, so there's the explicit
anomalous dimensions.
Let me keep that picture up.
So if you ask what path
independence means,
you could say path independence
could be phrased by the fact
that I could take
z inverse, and I
can take a commutator
of derivatives,
right, because I'm saying
that either order should
get the same result. And
if either order gives
the same result,
that must be zero.
And what this formula says that
the order that we're working
is that you can take
mu d by d mu of some,
say, nu anomalous
dimension, and that
should be equal to nu d by d nu
of the mu anomalous dimension.
That there's a connection
between the two things.
And if you look at the factors--
and if I wrote everything
down correctly,
then that's true and
likewise for the collinear.
So this is the
statement of there
not being a dependence
on the path.
These are formulas
that have to be true
if that's going to be true.
So I'm not going to write down
all these kernels for you.
There's a lot of them.
But just to give you
a flavor for what
the solutions look like,
they kind of look familiar.
Let me write down
a couple of them.
So I'll write down one.
I'll write the
ones for the soft.
So at leading log order,
what would they look like?
They're exponentials, Sudakov
logarithm type formulas.
They're not the same precise
formulas that we had earlier,
but they look kind of similar.
Let me write them down,
then I'll talk about them.
So these are running
along straight paths.
And they involve ratios
of alpha, basically.
[INAUDIBLE] that's what the
running coupling is doing.
So you could always write
things in such a way
that you don't have alphas
that involve nu, right,
because the rga just
has alphas of mu.
And so if you like,
when you're solving
the nu anomalous
dimension, this equation
is very easy to
integrate because there's
no nus on the right hand side.
You just get a log of nu.
And that's why this is--
that's why we have this
kind of simple log nu here.
Here I wrote alpha,
1 over alpha of nu s.
But I could have write that
back in terms of a log.
So it really isn't.
That was just convenient to
make it a simpler formula.
So if you write down the
evolution kernels like that,
they'll satisfy these
multiplication properties
that this figure implies.
And I won't go through
that, but it's kind of
neat to see how it works out.
All right, so that gives you
an idea of how we would sum
logs for this Sudakov form
factor with these two cut offs.
We just have the evolution
kernels and use them as usual.
But we have this more
complicated picture
of what type of
renormalization we have to do.
And you can think about
also, if you wanted to--
for example, say you wanted to
do this in some calculation,
and then you calculated
up to some order
solving these
anomalous dimensions.
And then you wanted
to vary scales.
Well, now you have a
two dimensional plane
to vary scales in, right?
So if you're varying
the soft scales,
you can kind of move around
in a box around this guy
where you're varying
both nu l and mu l
by kind of factors of 2.
And so they're
doing uncertainties
in this kind of
setup would have--
you'd have more parameters to
vary than you would usually
have just with mus.
But really, it's just a
straightforward generalization
of the one dimensional
picture of mu evolution
to a two dimensional
picture of nu evolution.
And the interesting
part is the kind
of overlaps between
these parameters.
So let me give you one other
physics example of where
this comes in just
so that you see
it's not just this one example.
So I'll just go through
one of them in detail,
and I'll just mention
one other one.
So it'll be two examples, but
we'll only really cover one.
So one thing you can
do is do gg to Higgs,
so Higgs production,
where I measure
a particular distribution,
which is the pt distribution,
pt of the Higgs.
And it turns out
that this process
involves rapidity divergences.
So let me try to
draw one picture that
allows me to capture all the
different degrees of freedom.
So here's-- you could imagine
that this is your top loop,
but it's some short
distance thing.
And you can even
integrate out the top.
Think of it as an effective
operator coupling two gluons
to the Higgs.
And so I'm in the center of
mass frame of the collision.
So these guys are back to back.
So that means that one of them
is n collinear, and one of them
is n bar collinear.
So if n and n bar collinear
is coming in, annihilating
and producing a Higgs--
and because of what we're
measuring about the Higgs,
we're only measuring the pt.
If you think about
what radiation
you can have in the
final state, well, you
could have collinear radiation.
So here's some
collinear radiation.
And that radiation
has a small pt.
So that's allowed
in the final state.
If we have a pth distribution
and we think about the limit
pth much less than the mass
of the Higgs, so there's some
logs that you would want
to sum, for example.
So you could have
collinear modes
in the final state
that would fit
within this kind
of kinematic setup.
But you could also
have soft modes.
So soft modes have the same size
of pt as the collinear modes.
So they would be allowed,
and this propagator here
would be off shell.
So it's an [? set ?] 2 problem.
Because you're only
constraining a pt,
then it's [? set ?] 2
problem with n bar, n, and s.
So pt Higgs [INAUDIBLE]
order mh lambda,
and modes are these ones.
So we'll SCET two.
And you'd want to sum--
in this case, you'd want to sum
up double logs of pth over mh.
That's what you might
be interested in using
the effective theory to do.
OK, so you would go through
the procedure of factorizing
the cross section.
It's an inclusive calculation
in the sense that basically,
in the final state,
it's Higgs plus x,
right, where x is collinear
radiation or soft radiation.
And really, the process
is proton proton,
for example, the Higgs plus x.
So we would want to factorize
the cross section, amplitude
squared.
And here is kind of a
sketch of how that would go.
I won't go through the details.
So you could think of starting
with some operator where you've
already integrated out the top.
So you have a coupling
of a Higgs to two gluons,
and that happens, and this
gives you variant operator
with the field strengths.
And then you would do the
factorization procedure.
After you shift momenta
to some other states,
you can basically right
that is the factorization
for a matrix element
of two currents.
And you get some
hard function, which
is the Wilson coefficient
squared of this operator.
And then you get
some operators that
look like this, matrix
elements that look like this.
So there's some
proton matrix elements
where one of the proteins
is collinear, one of them
is n bar collinear.
And then there's a
soft matrix element
of some soft Wilson lines.
They're actually in the
adjoint representation.
So I wrote transpose
rather than dagger.
So these are adjoint
representation.
They should be in the same
representation as the collinear
fields, and the collinear
fields here were gluons, right?
So when you go through
the field redefinition,
you would get adjoint
Wilson lines for the soft.
If you went through an [? set ?]
1, for example, picture,
and then the g [? mu nu is ?]
here would become
the perpendicular
polarization of the gluons.
So these things here are
going to give gluon PDFs.
So basically, you have
a factorization theorem
that involves gluon
PDFs and a soft function
and a hard function.
Now if you look at
this calculation,
you have three modes.
There's an [? set ?] 2.
They live on the same hyperbola.
And you do have
rapidity divergences
in this calculation.
So it's a story like this one.
And I'm not going to
go in too much detail,
but just let me write down the
factorization theorem for you
with all the mus
and nus explicit.
And it's really the
same picture where
the soft modes and
collinear modes
need to live at different nus.
Same mu, and then
there's the hard function
where you have to run
from one side to the next.
So it's really just-- you
keep the picture on the board.
It's applicable to
this example too.
So if you calculate d
sigma d, if you measure
rapidity of the Higgs boson--
so you can call this yh.
And you measure the pth
squared the magnitude
of the transverse momentum.
There's some normalization
factor, just kinematics.
There's a hard function
that only depends
on the Higgs mass and mu.
And then your other functions
can exchange [? perp ?] momenta
because the [? perp ?]
momenta of the soft function
and the [? perp momenta ?] of
these collinear functions are
the same size.
And what you're constraining
is just the total.
So the pt of the Higgs, if
the initial guys coming in
have zero [? perp ?]
momenta, there's
zero [? perp ?] momenta
for the protons by design.
So really, there's a balancing
between the final state
radiation and the Higgs,
which I can write like this.
OK, there's a delta
function, and then
you just have objects
for the different guys.
So do this in the proton
center of mass frame.
Because of the fact
that we're measuring
perpendicular momentum, it
allows the PDF to be a tensor.
But that kind of means it
has two scalar PDFs in it.
[INAUDIBLE] h.
And then there's
a soft function.
OK, so it's kind of got
the same type of structure
that we were seeing in
our previous example.
The external kinematics actually
fixes these variables here,
which are like the x.
This is like the [INAUDIBLE] x.
And the kinematics
of the process
actually end up
fixing that when you
go through the factorization.
This should be a plus sign here.
So the only thing that can
change from the dynamics
is the [? perp ?] momentum.
That's what gets exchanged
between these guys.
So you would sum logs by having
normalization group equations
for these objects.
And you need them in mu and nu.
The nu one is always kind of
simple because of the alpha
doesn't depend on nu.
So it's very simple
to integrate.
You just get one log.
But it's still an
important thing
because that one
log is something
that you can't get
from the mu evolution.
OK, so these are called
transverse momentum dependent
PDFs.
So they're not the
standard PDFs that you're
used to thinking about.
They have this dependence
on transverse momentum.
And because of that dependence
on transverse momentum,
they also have these
rapidity divergences.
And these are the renormalized
ones at this nu scale.
So there's a long, sordid
history of these guys.
They were introduced in
the early days of QCD,
and people have really only
sort it out very recently,
both in the QCD literature
and the SET literature
kind of simultaneously
with different regulators,
exactly how to make
sense of these guys
and define them properly and
renormalize them properly.
So this is kind of the last
couple of years type stuff.
So another example
that we could do which
I won't go through in detail--
so that was example one.
We could do an example that
is not involving protons
but involving jets
in e plus e minus.
So we could do e plus e
minus to [? dijets. ?]
And if we did something
similar to what we did here
where we only
measured a pt, then we
would also be in this
[? set ?] 2 situation.
So jet broadening
is a variable b
for broadening where it's like
an event shaped like thrust.
But you only measure
perpendicular momentum.
And what you
measure are actually
perpendicular to
the thrust axis.
So you still use thrust to
get the axis for the jet.
But then you don't
measure anything like
the minus or plus momentum.
You just measure pts.
This would be another
example, which is SCET 2,
and it actually would have,
again, cn, cn bar type modes.
And it-- you'd
[? read ?] a formula
not exactly the same as
this one but again involving
similar types of things--
collinear jet functions that
depend on pt, soft function,
some constraint between them.
It's a little more
complicated, actually,
than this pt Higgs one,
which is why I chose
to write down the pt Higgs one.
So I write that in my notes,
but just because of time,
I'm going to skip it
for our discussion.
So questions so far.
So really, it's turn the
crank once you believe some
of the things I've told you.
So something that
might be interesting
would be to work out
with mu evolution,
we have constraints on the
counter terms at all higher
orders that you can write
down by consistency,
anomalous dimension equations.
And I don't think there's to
my knowledge in the literature
an expression like that
for two loops, three loops,
what would the various
1 over etas and 1
over epsilons, how
would they have
to work out based on the
consistency of the picture I've
told you.
I don't think
anyone's done that.
That would be kind
of interesting.
All right, so questions-- none.
Good.
All right, so one final example.
So presentations Monday--
they're not in this room.
They're in the seminar room,
the large CPT seminar room.
It's on the fourth floor.
And I have also
made a note that you
should use the blackboard, which
will stop you from preparing
too much information.
OK, so let's do
one final example.
The final example I
want to talk about
is Drell-Yan, which we almost
kind of talked about already.
But I'd like to talk about it
in a little different context.
So we talked about pp
to xh, Higgs boson.
Classic Drell-Yan is
pp to xl plus l minus.
But kinematically, that doesn't
really make too much difference
from having a Higgs boson here.
So I will talk about this
in a little more detail
than I did the Higgs example.
We'll go through some
of the kinematics
in a little more detail.
So the reason that I want
to talk about this process
is there's kind of one
function that we haven't yet
seen that will show up
in our discussion here,
one kind spread function
that's ubiquitous
and shows up in all sorts
of factorization theorems.
And we haven't seen it yet.
So what are the kinematics?
We have some momentum.
Let me do it this way.
Let me write it below this guy.
So pa for the proton,
pb for the other proton,
goes equals p for the x plus
q for the l plus l minus pair.
So what are the
important variables?
Well, there's the center of
mass, energy of the collision.
That's just s in
Mandelstam variables,
but I'll call it ECM so
you remember what it is.
pa plus pb all squared--
that's the collision energy.
That's ATV [INAUDIBLE]
[? LHC, ?] soon to be higher.
There's q squared,
and that's the scale
of the hard collision.
So the hard collision scale is
not the center of mass energy.
You take a parton out of each
proton, and those collide.
And they carry a
fraction of that energy.
You can see how
much you have been
looking at how hard the leptons
are, and that's q squared.
It's useful to talk about the
dimensionless variable, which
is [INAUDIBLE].
And that's the ratio of these
two variables, which is always
less than or equal to 1.
And then you can talk about
the rapidity of the leptons.
And you can write that in a kind
of Lorentz invariant looking
way by having a pb
dot q and a pa dot q.
Start using capitals.
So this variable is like
the theta for the leptons.
So theta q.
So again, it's just
like our Higgs example,
but let me draw it in
a little different way.
You can think about doing
everything in a cm frame.
Protons are coming
in back to back.
So then you have
collinear particles
because your protons
are very energetic.
So if this is a quark and
this is an anti-quark,
you produce a virtual photon.
And the virtual photon
produces a lepton pair.
So here's an n collinear
quark and an n bar collinear
anti-quark.
So the anti-quark is
coming in that way,
quark is coming in that way.
They annihilate, produce
a virtual photon.
That produces a lepton pair.
That's Drell-Yan.
OK, so in the cn
frame, we're going
to have cn modes, cn bar
modes, for the protons
and the anti-proton.
Some other variables that
are useful to talk about
are something that people
call xa and xb, which
are the Bjorken variables.
And they already showed up
in our previous example,
but let me just define them.
So these are taking tau and
taking the square root of it
and then splitting up
the rapidity e to the y
and e to the minus y.
And these are like analogs
of the Bjorken variable
for this problem.
And it's actually
these combinations
that are showing up here.
So if you put in
what tau is, that's
explaining what
these arguments were.
They're just the xa and xb.
And kinematics, you
can work out that tau
is less than or equal to xa or
b and that they're less than
or equal to 1.
So there's some
simple bounds on them.
And then finally,
you can work out
that x squared,
if you square it,
is less than or equal to ecm
squared 1 minus square root
of tau all squared.
And one more thing
that you have are
sort of the parton
distribution fractions.
So parton time
distribution variables,
and they're bounded
just like dis.
So xa and xb are things that
are, if you like leptonic,
you might call them that.
But they're things that are
external to the QCD, right?
They're just
measuring properties
of the leptons, q squared, the
center of mass of the equation,
and y, which is a y
of the leptons too.
So everything here is
not a QCD variable.
And then there's
these QCD variables ca
and cb, which are inside
the parton distributions.
And they're bounded.
Just like we had a bound
in dis, x less than
or equal to c, less
than or equal to 1,
here, we have two
analogs of that formula.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART:
Yeah, that's right.
The rapidity of the q--
so really, this is like--
I mean, this is my kind of--
this is like log of--
the thing that's
important here is
the log of q plus or q minus.
It's the rapidity of the q.
Yeah, you could talk about
measuring individual things
about the leptons, but
then you would just
be tacking something
onto the q and taking
something else out of it.
All right, so what kind of--
so this is just some kinematics.
What kind of limits do
we want to think about?
So we already talked
about one example
where we would measure q perp.
That's what we were
doing in the Higgs case.
And I'm not going to
talk about that case.
I'll talk about
three other cases.
So if we didn't measure
q perp, then there's
kind of three
different things we
could do that I'll talk about.
Let's see.
Organize my board better.
I'll tell you about
the kinematics
of each one of
these, and then I'll
draw a little
picture for each one.
So in the inclusive
process, this
is the analog of what we did
for deep elastic scattering.
So deep elastic scattering,
we set the Bjorken x variables
of order 1.
Here we could say
that some sense, tau
is of order 1 as well as
xa and xb are of order 1.
And in this case, what
you're saying about px
squared is that it's hard.
It's of order 2 squared,
and if tau is of order 1,
than that's of
order ecm squared.
So these things are
all hard variables.
And in this case,
the way you should
think about what's
happening in the process
is the following picture.
So you have your partons coming
in or your protons coming in.
And basically, you're allowing
radiation that's hard anywhere.
So hard is supposed to be pink.
You're not constraining
the radiation.
You're really allowing hard
radiation [INAUDIBLE] hard.
Your x is hard and you
allow jets in any direction,
for example.
And then somewhere,
there's a lepton pair.
[INAUDIBLE] purple.
But it's not constrained either.
It's really fairly general.
My picture is too big.
I'm going to run it [INAUDIBLE].
Oh well.
We'll do this.
So I want to draw analogous
pictures for the other cases.
So in the end point, you're
taking a different limit.
What you're doing is you're
taking this tau goes to 1.
And you can see from over
here that if tau goes to 1,
that forces xa
and xb to go to 1.
And if xa and xb go to 1, that
forces ca and cb to go to 1.
So you're really
talking about probing
the proton in a very
special kinematics
where everything is going to 1.
And you're basically
in the hard collision,
you're forcing all the energy
to go into the parton that's
colliding.
So the proton, the
full proton momentum,
goes into the active parton.
Let me just say it that
way-- active parton.
So that changes the
picture because it also--
if you look at it,
when tau goes to 1,
it says the outgoing energy,
the full ecm squared,
is going into q squared, which
is the leptonic variable.
So all the energy is
coming in on the partons
and going out on the leptons.
So you don't have hard
radiation like this anymore.
The only thing that
you could possibly have
is soft radiation.
So in this case, what
happens is this picture--
make my lepton a
little shorter--
changes.
You still, of course, have these
incoming guys, but what happens
is that everything
outgoing is soft.
So make it green.
You have soft
radiation like that.
And then it turns out
also that in this case,
the leptons end up having to be
back to back because you can't
have any transverse momentum.
That would be-- there's nothing
for the transverse momentum
to recoil against.
So that's a possibility.
And then there's a third
thing that we'll talk about,
which is what I call isolated.
And it in some sense is trying
to combine these two pictures
here without taking
a limit on tau.
So you might say, well,
what's the most typical event
at the LHC?
Where is most of the
cross-section for this process?
And that would be
in a situation where
tau is not in the endpoint.
It doesn't go to 1.
It's kind of an order
1 quantity, actually.
You typically get xa's and
xb's that are like 0.1 or 0.01,
small x's for--
depends on what q
squared you look at.
But the typical ones you're
interested in are small x's.
So you don't want x to go to 1.
So tau can be of order 1.
But if you ask what the most
probable thing for the px
to do, if you have these
collinear particles coming in
and they start
radiating, well, they
like to radiate
collinear particles.
So the most likely
thing that will happen
is that you'll get
collinear radiation
from the incoming particles.
And you can look
at that by studying
the following situation
where you constrain
px squared to be 2 ISR jets.
So the picture--
we'll talk about how
we do that in a minute.
But-- or one way of doing it.
So the picture would
then be as follows.
We have these incoming
guys, which now I'm
going to try to draw
some radiation for.
So here are some colors.
So here's a collinear
guy in one direction.
Here's a collinear guy
in the other direction.
And they can radiate.
They radiate prior to
the hard collision here.
So you're getting some jets from
these guys that look like this
and then from this guy a
symmetric thing like that.
And then in the central
part of the collision,
you just allow soft radiation.
So this is the
isolated scenario.
And if I draw the
leptons, it turns out
they don't have to
be back to back,
but there is some constraint
on their kinematics.
Basically, they're back to back
in the transverse plane but not
longitudinally.
But we won't dwell on that.
OK, so this is the sort of
third kinematic configuration.
So even though we're
interested in one process,
we've already just
described to you
four different ways
that you could think
about looking at it.
And those four
different ways will
lead to four different
factorization theorems
because it's a different
kinematic setup.
The first one was
pt of the Higgs.
That led to this rapidly
divergent type factorization
theorem.
Inclusive we'll talk about in
a minute, what it looks like.
Endpoint and isolated, they all
will have different formulas
for the factorization
theorem, and that's
because they look different.
I really should say that
this is ultra soft, not soft.
And so this is
ultra soft too here.
This is ultra soft.
This is cn radiation,
and this is cn bar.
All right, so let's
see how far we get.
OK, so let's start
with inclusive.
So the x is hard.
And so the way you
can think about it
is that what you're
doing is that you have--
you can use kind of an
optical theorem type picture
where you're cutting
these forward graphs.
These are the leptons
here, which are
the things in the final state--
so vertical photon.
And I'm squaring it.
And in comes qq bar
and then squaring it,
so qq bar on that side as well.
And then if you think about it,
every kind of radiation gluon
that I would put across this cut
I can think of as kind of hard.
And so I can integrate it out.
And so what you're going to get
is if you just think about this
process, when you match
the cross-section,
you're going to get some four
quark operator in [? SCT. ?] So
this will match
on to an operator,
which is a four quark operator
where two of the quarks are n
collinear--
I'll draw it like this--
and two of them are
n bar because that's
the external particles.
We have qn, q bar, n bar.
So we're going to get that.
And that we know how to
write down the lowest order
operator for that.
That's just going to be chi bar
chi, chi bar chi, chi bar chi.
So we have a four
quark operator in SCET,
which you can ride after
doing a [INAUDIBLE]
in the spin with all the n
collinear fields together.
You can work out constraints
on the [? rack ?] structure.
There's only one
operator, basically.
It's not quite true.
So you could have
a gluon operator,
an operator with
four gluon fields,
that's the analog of this one.
Then you would have to have some
higher order diagram in order
to take those gluons
and attach a photon.
It would have to be a quark
loop inside the hard function.
But you could also have a
gluon operator with four b's.
So let me just say there's
also bn, bn, bn bar, bn bar.
So you don't have a color
octet structure-- no ta, ta.
And again, that's like
our bdd pi example
where if you had
that structure, it
would vanish when you
take matrix elements.
So there's no ta,
ta, just constraints
on the color contractions.
Here, these guys would
have to be contracted.
Those guys would have
to be contracted.
You can make the
field redefinition.
The field redefinition
the y's would cancel out.
So there's no ultrasofts here.
[INAUDIBLE] leading order.
And if you take these matrix
elements of these objects,
you can kind of guess what
they're going to give.
This is just giving a PDF.
Each of these are giving a PDF.
And they're the regular
PDFs, the standard ones.
Because we didn't measure
a [? perp ?] momentum,
we just get standard PDFs.
So some parton
inside the proton,
which would be a gluon from
these guys-- gluon PDFs
are quarks from these guys.
And it depends on
some x [INAUDIBLE] mu.
x could be xa or x--
x could be ca or cb.
So let me just write ca.
And that's really all you get.
So you have a hard function
and then two collinear parton
distribution functions.
So the cross section--
[INAUDIBLE] these limits
that we talked about
come from the kinematics.
[INAUDIBLE] some hard
function, which is an inclusive
hard function.
Like in DIS, it depends on
the ratio of these variables.
But now there's two of them.
just depends on q
squared, depends on mu.
And then there's times PDFs.
There's an important
caveat here,
which is if you want
to derive this result,
you have to make sure that
the degrees of freedom
I've told you with the degrees
of freedom are the right ones.
So what did I tell you?
I told you we have cn, cn
bar, and ultra soft, right?
And that from the
kinematics, it's a SCET one.
Turns out there's one other
type of degree of freedom
that you could worry
about, and that's
called the Glauber gluon?
And to derive this, we must
know that that doesn't matter.
What is a Glauber gluon?
It's a Coulombic gluon
between n and m bar particles.
So it's a Coulombic
type potential
that goes like 1 over
pt vector squared.
And that's a Glauber.
It's called a Glauber exchange.
So it's not an
on-shell particle.
It's like a potential.
But you have to know that those
actually are relevant in order
to get to this formula.
So there's a little
more work involved which
I'm not going to talk about.
OK, but-- and that's going
to be true, actually,
of all the other cases
that we do as well.
So what about this
threshold limit?
How does this formula change?
Well, you could think about
how the formula changes.
It's really a change of this
h in the threshold limit
because what's
happening is that you're
constraining the pink
radiation and making it green.
[INAUDIBLE] keep my pictures.
So if we want to go from here
to here for the threshold limit,
then only certain terms, if you
like, in the HIJ are included.
So if you wrote out that
function, really what
it corresponds to is that
only the most singular
terms in the variable 1 minus
tau in these 1 minus type
variables are included.
So delta functions
of 1 minus tau,
plus functions of
1 minus tau, those
are the terms that you
would include from the h
whereas the inclusive
one has much more in it.
This keeps only
particular terms.
But there's also different
hierarchies of scales
because now 1 minus tau is
small, and you want to--
for example, some logs of 1
minus tau in this situation.
And that's what the
factorization theorem
in this threshold
region does for you.
So the HIJ inclusive gets
turned into the following.
This is the modification of
the factorization theorem.
So there's a soft function
for that soft radiation.
And then there's a different
heart function, which is only
a function of q squared.
And it's like the square--
this guy here is the square
of a Wilson coefficient again,
and i and j are just pairs
of quarks-- uu bar, dd bar.
There's actually no
gluons in this case.
So the terms of the gluon
PDFs actually get suppressed.
They're not singular
in 1 minus tau,
and we get this formula here.
And now there's going
to be some running
that you have to do between the
hard scale and the soft scale,
and that running is going to
sum up these logarithms of 1
minus tau.
OK, so I'm not going to go
through that in any more
detail.
I'll spend a little
more time on this one.
So what about
isolated Drell-Yan?
This one is a little bit
different than the other ones
because we have to measure
something about the process
to know that it looks like
this if we really want to drive
a factorization theorem.
Here, we were measuring tau.
But now I'm telling you I
don't want to measure tau.
Yet I still want
to distinguish--
so I don't want to measure tau.
I don't want to constrain
it to be close to 1.
But I still want to distinguish
between these two, right?
And if I'm going to distinguish
between those two situations,
I need to measure
something else.
And we can measure something
that's exactly like what we did
when we did e plus e minus to
[? dijets ?] because this is
really like [? dijets. ?] But
they're just initial stage jets
rather than final stage jets.
So that's what
we're going to do.
We only have four jets.
We have tau that's generic.
So the c's are not
being forced to go to 1.
And so we need something that
we can observe to do that.
And here's what we can do.
Let's do something
that's the analog of e
plus e minus to [? dijets ?] but
for these initial stage jets.
So we say that px is a sum of
momentum in two hemispheres.
The hemispheres a and b
are just the dividing line
of the center of mass of the
collision-- so very simple,
perpendicular to the beam axis.
And then we just
say that ba plus--
so this is just a [? four ?]
momentum decomposition.
But we can look
at ba plus, which
is like dotting the n vector
for one axis into ba--
and that's a sum over particles
in one of the hemispheres
and then likewise for b.
So this is if I
write it in terms
of energies and rapidities.
It'll look like this.
So this is some
observable ba plus.
And then I can constrain that
ba plus, which is exactly
like constraining the
plus momentum in one
of the hemispheres to be small.
And what that does, if you
constrain the plus momentum
in this hemisphere
to be small, it
will allow ultra soft radiation
because they have small plus
momentum.
And it'll allow
collinear radiation
because they have
small plus momentum.
So constraining
ba plus constrains
all the ba plus momentum
in that hemisphere.
And that puts you in
an SCET one situation
where we have a
figure like that one.
So rather than constrain
the [? perp ?] momentum,
we constrain the plus.
And then we get SCET one.
So take ba plus to be
less than or something,
which you could say, well,
less than or equal to some cut.
Let's just call it b cut.
And that is much less than q.
And then we do the
same thing for b plus,
which we define as
nb, which is na bar.
So the notation here
is a little awkward,
but we do the same thing here.
So this is less than or
equal to some cut and that
that's much less than q.
And by demanding
small plus momentum
in both hemispheres,
appropriate momentum
with the small components--
these are the small components--
that puts us in a
SCET one situation.
So we have cn, cn
bar, and ultra soft.
And those are the allowed
types of radiation,
and that's what I
drew in my figure.
So hopefully that's clear.
All right, so what does
the factorization look
like in this case?
Well, you have two
types of things
that are collinear if
you look at the figure.
There's the initial
state proton, right,
which came in here, and
it was collinear here.
So here's a proton.
And then it's cruising
along, and at some point,
it widens out like
this and becomes a jet.
So this here is collinear at a
smaller scale than this here.
This is a jet, right?
It's got large invariant mass
relative to the proton mass.
So there's actually two
types of collinears,
and if you really want to draw
the mode picture for this,
here's what it would look like.
So here's our collinear
hyperbola cn cn bar.
We have an ultra soft hyperbola.
And then somewhere, we have
a lambda qcd hyperbola.
And there's protons that
sit on the lambda qcd.
So this is like pn bar,
if you like, or let
me give it a different name--
pn.
Then there's hard modes.
So what we'll do
is we'll not really
worry about
distinguishing these.
We'll think of
them all together.
So we'll just have
[? sct ?] one,
where we have ultra softs
here, a cn, and a cn bar.
But then we'll later have
to worry about factoring.
This includes the jet.
This is the collinear jet.
And this is the proton, right?
So both objects will be in the
same function at the beginning,
and then we'll have
to factor them later
if we want to
separate those scales.
It's a similar trick to what we
used before in another example.
It was for soft in that case.
So if we just keep
these guys together,
then it's just a SCET one.
Just have these modes go
through the factorization.
And this is what we get.
So we can measure q
squared, rapidity,
and we can measure these
two hemisphere momenta.
The hard function is again the
square of a Wilson coefficient
just as it was in
the threshold case.
We get some collinear functions
that are called beam functions,
and they're like, they
have an argument that's
a plus times a minus momentum.
So this wa is like
a minus momentum.
We have a Bjorken x variable.
And we have mu.
There's one of these
for each direction.
So there's one for
the b direction too.
And then there's
a soft function.
And it's a hemisphere
soft function.
It's really exactly analogous
to the soft function that we had
in e plus e minus,
the [? dijets, ?]
except that the Wilson lines are
incoming instead of outgoing.
So it depends on two
plus momenta in mu.
OK, so the factorization theorem
involves these b's, which
are called beam functions.
So this is a beam
function, four parton i.
And parton i could be a quark
or a gluon in this case.
Well, sorry, parton i here
will be a quark, actually,
in this case--
quark or a q bar.
You have analogous
functions for gluons as well
that would come in,
for example, if you
were doing Higgs production.
So what is this beam function?
It's the one object
that we haven't
seen an example of before.
And it's really a matrix
element of an operator
that we've studied in
many different situations.
It's just the chi
bar chi operator
with different arguments than
we've studied previously.
So it's a slightly different
matrix element of the chi bar
chi operator because
what we're measuring
is both the large momentum
and the small momentum
of that operator.
When we measured just the large
momentum, that gave us the PDF.
But now we're measuring
also the small momentum,
which I can write like this.
So it's a protein matrix element
of a chi bar chi operator
where if it was a PDF,
this would be 0 and 0,
and we just have
the minus momentum.
But now we're
measuring, if you like,
the other momentum, which
is like a plus momentum.
And I wrote it in Fourier space.
So the plus momentum that
you're measuring is here.
Those are the two variables
that are showing up
on the right hand side as
well as the minus momentum
of the proton.
So it's just a different
matrix element than one
we've had before.
The jet function, remember,
would be vacuum matrix element
of chi bar chi, and
the PDF, standard PDF,
would be proton matrix
element of chi bar delta chi.
And it's just really--
the arguments are
slightly different,
and that allows this
thing to contain both kind
of a jet, initial state jet--
in this case here,
the jet function,
you'd have some variable zero.
In this case here,
you'd have 0 and 0.
And so if you
like, what this guy
is is just a combination of the
two things we studied before.
We studied the jet function.
We studied the PDF.
Now this has both inside it.
And if we go through this final
factorization between there
and there, then that's like a
SCET one to SCET two matching.
And so we can integrate out the
perturbative radiation, which
is the jet function, right?
That's perturbative.
And this is non-perturbative.
We can separate those by
doing another matching,
and that gives a factorization
theorem for the b alone
that looks like this.
So there's some perturbative
matching coefficients
which are called i.
And then you get a standard PDF.
So this i is the thing that
has in it the jet radiation.
This is sort of
an i for the jet.
And then this is the PDF.
OK, and the T scale
here is large.
And what you're
basically expanding
in is you're expanding
in lambda QCD over t.
So if you ask what am I doing
to make that separation,
I'm expanding in
lambda QCD over t.
There's no t here.
The t is perturbative.
That's the scale for the jet.
And this f is a non-perturbative
distribution function.
And that's then the full
factorization theorem
putting those things together.
So these beam
functions are kind of--
they are things that
show up whenever
you have a process where you
ask for a particular number
of jets.
And if you asked, for
example, for a particular--
if you ask for two--
if you ask for this
setup plus one more jet,
how would things change?
Well, you'd have the
same beam radiation,
the same initial
state radiation.
And you'd add one more jet
function to this formula.
So that would be exclusive
one jet production.
Or you could have two jets.
Then you'd have
two jet functions.
In each case, you have a
different soft function.
But these beam
functions are going
to be always showing up
because they're describing
this initial state radiation.
So any time that's an allowed
thing, then it'll show up.
If you start doing
[? perp ?] measurements,
then you might have
[? perp-dependent ?] beam
functions in the same
way that we could get
[? perp-dependent ?] PDF.
In some sense, a
[? perp-dependent ?] PDF is
like a beam function.
So that's kind of
the last function
that you need to know about that
is kind of a generic thing that
shows up with these
factorizations theorems.
And we're out of time.
So let's stop there.
And that's it.
See you on Monday.